la peinture à l'huile à avait plus des
wc le feu c'est bien plus haut que la
peinture à l'eau
c'est bientôt terminé quasi nul presque
parce que le vent va être magnifique
encore plus beau que l'arc en ciel étant
dès que j'ai mis 5 bonne couche de
peinture il sera très moelleux avant
parce que tu crois que la teinture une
fois sèche sera plus bas les audois et
alors ça va ça va casimir tu te fâche
pas et toi léonard ça marche aussi ça
marche ça court
quand j'aurai passé la deuxième couche
le kiosque sera comme neuf rageux livre
est contente la peinture à l'huile à
cebu des faits ici la miss a dit bien
plus beau que la peinture à l'eau et aux
lacets toi j'ai terminé moi aussi mon
coin ci étant donné que nous avons tous
fini on compense très tôt d'aller
prendre un bon bain à la plage une très
bonne idée dit avec nous lyonnais
non non non merci moi je préfère gagner
ma malle pourrait faire une petite
sieste réparatrice aurait bien pu voir
vieux renard paresseux on y va parfois
le premier vient la plage à vos marques
prêts
il a complètement oublié qu'il fallait
installer les pancartes pourquoi les
gens ne se mettent pas plein de peinture
fraîche heureusement quand je suis là et
que je prends ça court grassement les
pancartes
alors j'y comprends rien il n'y a plus
qu'une peau carte une forme oui oh là là
ça va être en béton puisque nous avons
repris trois choses et il n'a qu'une
pancarte
bon ça ne fait rien j'ai une idée je
vais l'installer au milieu du jardin à
égale distance
dans la cage à poules du kiosque et du
barça tout le monde comprendra qu'il y à
de la peinture fraîche partout ouais
espérons le allez jean rejoint françois
saluait sa princesse
bon ben la sieste
c'est moi qui vais la faire
vite vite mademoiselle julie à boire
j'en ai un bon soir
pour sûr c'est pas de chance le kiosque
est complètement désert ça fait là je
vais je veux un petit peu morose et je
vais m'asseoir un petit morin ça me fera
du bien une pancarte
attention à la peinture
voudrais bien savoir de quelle peinture
il s'agit or c'est sûrement la chaise de
françois qui a été repeinte haut alors
je vais aller me mettre sur le banc oui
il ne tend les bras à
un petit peu de repos au milieu de la
tournée ça fait vraiment du bien j'ai
oublié mon peignoir de bain
catastrophe mais les facteurs mais que
faites vous là enfin vous n'avez pas lu
la pancarte attention à la peinture
rassure toi à casimir j'ai bien vu la
pancarte je ne me suis pas assis sur la
chaise de françois et ce n'est pas la
chaise qui a été repeinte alors qu'est
ce que c'est eh bien c'est la cage à
poule à a
je ne m'en suis pas approché
la classe quant à julie je vais même pas
effleuré
et la bonté le banc le bon
bout mettant à l'eau aux catastrophes et
tout recommencer ma salle à la belle
affaire le levant c'est pas grave mais
les pantalons fait à venir je me
changeais jeux covan on n'allait pas
question vous allez rester là et refaire
tout ce travail que les pros il ya juste
ce qu'il faut ici
et moi je vais un peu rapproché la
pancarte du banc comme ceux ci plus
personne ça sert à dessus j'espère
c'est pourtant pas difficile à
comprendre par tension à la peinture
pour sûr
ouh là là là là là là je suis épuisé je
m'en souviendrai de cette promenade en
forêt avec mademoiselle futé 20 km à
pied et qui plus est il faut que je
porte ces branches que la ramasser
je n'en peux plus
je vais pouvoir maaf aller sur ce banc
attention à la peinture
la chaise et le banc sont
bons bon je vais m'installer dans la
cage à poules
oh
allez encore un petit effort julie c'est
le dernier de la journée
me suis pas très bien comme ça voyons
moi
ça n'est pas beaucoup de milieux bon
voilà là c'est merveilleux
comme on est bien tranquille
casimir
casimir valeur casimir tu l'as trouvé
oui ou non son peignoir de bain penses
toi je t'en prie créé un peu moins fort
je me repose
mais qu'est ce que tu fais la route dans
la cage à poules c'est interdit chez
nous c nous vite et c'est pas interdit
mais c'est donc c'est pas conseillé ces
nouveaux pourquoi bien parce que là la
cage à poules viennent d'être repeinte
je fais tu là
où j'en ai plein de marans et sont
ailleurs il ya une pente hier qu'il
explique très clairement ici un bon jeu
lui pas vu la pancarte où est elle mais
casimir du récent d'occuper un peu tu
veux parler peut-être de cette pancarte
la mort mais oui julie me grille avant
également une pancarte sur la cage à
poules et et une autre sur ton qui est
ce qu'il n'y ait pas
parce que vous avez pas mon cas c'est
assez gentil
et puis j'ai retrouvé mon peignoir des
émirs regarde ce qui est arrivé à julie
par ta faute voilà mais enfin elle
n'avait pas besoin la pancarte attention
à la peinture et la pancarte elle était
sur la chaise elle était pas sur la cage
à poules oui m'enfin si on a quand même
pu deviner
enfin je vois on itunes app adeline et
non à l'étudier à françois on va à la
plage casimir
julie et noah et nous allons aller à la
plage oui et moi alors je joue je vais
rester tout semble exactement si vaste
et si casimir péret qu'est ce que je
vais faire alors dire je l'expliquais
tu vois cette jolie carte et émirs et
marqué
par cette porte car printemps sur la
facture
[Musique]
attention à la peinture
attention à la peinture faites attention
ne vous appuyer pas sur le bord il vient
d'être repeint enfin ta passion la
peinture redescendez vite de la cage à
tout va et vient d'être repeint à neuf
vous allez vous salir faites attention
méfiez-vous de la peinture ne vous
appuyer pas sur le kiosque 1 il est tout
fraîchement repeints attention à la
peinture à attention
[Musique]
vous allez bien moi j'ai passé une
excellente journée grâce à l'aide de
julie mon étude sur les feuillages de
l'île aux enfants progressent très
rapidement
tenez écoutez je viens juste de terminer
mais compte deux cent cinquante quatre
feuilles de chêne 112 feuilles des
marronniers et 56 les deux autres
mademoiselle chutait au même petit
canadien d'abord je ne suis pas entre
canaries en sucre ensuite vous ne devez
pas rester assise sur le banc
très bien puisque c'est comme ça je vais
saluer julie
les balades mauvais caractère
normal on ne vous approchez pas du curé
enfin casimir ou faut-il aller pour ne
pas t'avoir constamment dans les genres
vous voulez donc la cage à poules là moi
je suis certaine que la qui ne pourra
pas venir me rejoindre j'espère enfin
pour m'installer pour réfléchir voyager
cendres de là tout de suite hein pas
pourquoi là où la cage à poules de même
comme le kiosque et la bande ont été
repeints il ya juste deux heures au
maximum
et où eva me prévenir plutôt j'espère
enfin je veux tout la jupe de tâches
aimé
mais tu te moques de moi casimir
m'écoute j'ai pas la plus petites taches
de peinture je ne comprends là tout a
été repeint pourtant en casimir
peinture elle est formidable
j'ai lu le mode d'emploi est sèche en
1h30 c'est bon alors je comprends tout
je sais ce qu'il me reste à faire alors
voila si simple que ça
nous fait plus attention à la peinture à
ne fait plus attention à la peinture
vous pouvez jouer partout ne fait plus
attention à la peinture elle est sèche
ne fait plus attention à la peinture
vous pouvez monter
[Musique]